Hello everybody, this is Dr. Connors again with section six of stop fighting cancer.
Thanks for downloading the book. I hope this little program is helping you and
we are going to get into some more exciting stuff, but things that I really like to do with
not only helping people with issues of cancer, but live and all sorts of different disorders.
We start to talk today about the right machine. Now I understand we have a variety of
different groups of people that are listening to this and reading this information
and searching for hope online. And when you ask somebody about a right machine,
some people might have some knowledge and most people have zero knowledge. What in the world is a
right machine and why would I want to use one? Well, I cannot explain it all in this
little presentation. Again, I mentioned on a previous presentation that I have a about a 20-minute
presentation on our website that explains the right. Again, that is an overview. You can't
explain somebody's life in 20 minutes and all the work of their scientific work of their entire
life and really a couple generations of work in a short presentation, but at least it gives you
an overview. So Royal Raymond Rife is the person we're talking about and that is who a right machine
is named after. Royal Rife was a microscope manufacturer. In fact, he really created the first
live cell microscope. He received multiple accolades. He was had dinners in his honor. He was
considered by many. It is time to be a scientific genius. Maybe not quite in the order of Tesla
but he was quite the genius. In his microscope, he was able to see live bacteria and live virus. That's
where he what a lot of accolades that he could see a live virus in a person's blood sample.
And he could then through the use of frequencies that epilate that virus or that bacteria and that
single cell organism and he could kill it. So he took microbes pathogens and by using a frequency
generator and what he ended up ultimately creating was a light frequency generator and using that
light frequency generator he could kill those pathogens. He thought that he was was licing the walls
of the pathogen but thereby killing it. That's what he believed at the time. Now we know that there's
multiple reasons why right right light frequency generators work. That is actually what he
considered. The main reason is now considered a minor reason. It works on a quantum
frequent quantum physics frequency level. It can be super beneficial. That being said, it is solely
a tool. It is like any other tool that needs to be used correctly. Though you can't really do any
harm with the right machine, you could use it and do little good as well. So if you're trying to
help a person with cancer and using a right machine, if you're not hitting the frequencies of that
person's cancer, you're going to do very little good to that person. Maybe you see spending time
on it all for not. Same thing with if you're trying to kill a Lyme disease or a bacterial infection or
a virus or something like that. If you're not hitting the frequency of that organism, you're not
really going to do a lot of good for that patient. So much of our time is spent trying to figure out
the frequencies to use. Remember that is the fourth pillar in our four pillars. Once the cause,
how are we going to get rid of the cause? What are we going to use for a nutraceutical standpoint
for that person's cancer? And fourth is what frequencies are we going to use? So the way we use
a right machine is we program it for the patient to typically use simply a night while they're sleepy.
So part of our philosophy of care and dealing with a person who has cancer is that I want them to be
less consumed with the treatment of their cancer and more consumed with seeing this as a bump in the
road and you have to use wisdom and make the right steps. But you got to move on and live your life.
I think I was dealing with stage 4 cancer and my life was consumed with killing the cancer.
I would be doing my loved ones at the service and spending the majority of my time trying to
get better and spending the majority of my time trying to live. Now I understand when you're in
the throes of a disorder, you need to take some time and deal with it. But what we want to do is make
the majority of the patient's treatment be at night while they're sleeping. So the use of the
right typically, unless the person is in quite a bad state, we typically only program night programs.
So they're treating their going to bed, opening up the computer, turning on the right machine,
running their specific program. We program Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday every night is
a different program. So if it's Monday, they'll open up their program, hit Monday night, hit run,
close the computer and they'll go to bed with the right machine. Now the light is a bulb that goes
in their bed or typically they might cuddle with it or might go behind their headboard in our house.
It goes over our headboard in between my wife and I. We don't actually see the light. It's behind
our pillows. So it doesn't disturb our sleep and we use it every single night. So that's what
typical cancer or line patient would do as well. They'll use it every night on the program that
we've created for them. If they're very, very ill and they're not ambulatory for any reason,
then I'll create day programs as well. They might as well use it while they're lying there.
Many times I'll create some short programs so if they're going to sit and watch a movie or you're
going to watch a football game, my wife will turn it on and get the benefit from it. It also comes
programmed with over a thousand different programs that we and other people have created
that are labeled for all sorts of different disorders. Now the right again is a tool.
It's a tool that works best on killing cancer cells. It works best on killing living organisms. It
really does very little good if a person has, you know, not cancer or a lie, but they have a heavy
metal toxicity. The right that she is not going to detox heavy metals or it's not going to detox chemicals.
It will help with the liver. It helps liver detox pathway so it'll do that
indirectly, but it's not going to kill it. Heavy metals out of a person's body. So the best use of a
right is it is with cancer, with a biotoxin, like a Lyme disease or a chronic mold or a chronic fungus,
or ideally with everyday things, people use it on a regular basis for their kids' strep infection
or ear infections or a total fungus or there's just a ton of different uses for the right
machine. So a cancer patient will say, how long do I have to use this? In my answer is you will
never want to not use it. It's a great tool. So even after you've overcome your critical stage of
cancer, you're going to still keep it by your bedside and turn it on every night while you're at home.
Once you get past that critical stage and you're doing so much better that you're going to take a
trip to Florida or wherever for a week, you just, you won't bring the right with you. So that's
something you're dependent upon, but it's a tool that is just so great to bring holostasis back
to your body on a cellular level. So you'll never read a lot about the right machine. You're never
going to see ads television about the right machine. There's just not enough money in the right
machine and selling the right machine to a patient to help them with cancer. You're never going to see
the hospital recommended it, but it is a machine that creates a light frequencies that will stimulate
those frequencies of the member and free thing down to its smallest particle from a quantum physics
standpoint is energy that vibrates at a specific frequency. So if you're stimulate that cancer at
its own frequency, it can bring residents back to that cancer. So it stops replicated. It could
cause lysis of that cancer cell, and it will alkalize the tissue around there because it acts as a pH
it raises the pH by donating an electron because it's a photon generator. So it is a great tool that
works well with so many different disorders. Now that short history of rife, he was eventually just
once the pharmaceutical industry literally took over the AMA, all the cancer doctors that
were not using pharmaceutical drugs were basically run out of the country, and that's where
you have the Mexico cancer clinics today. The Gerson clinic was Mexico. Gerson went to Mexico,
the Hoxy clinic in Mexico is that Hoxy left Texas and went to Mexico. He was basically shut down.
Well, when rife was shut down and his instruments were destroyed, he did not go to Mexico. Ironically,
he was the closest to Mexico of anybody. He lived in San Diego, but he was an older man at that time
and he literally died, a broken man. He just gave up everything. He just gave all his life's work
was destroyed, and the AMA did its job in destroying anything that was in competition to them.
That was the day at the time. They don't think they're so vicious anymore. Some people might disagree
with that, but that's just the facts. So, you won't read a lot about it in the news, but it is a great
tool. It's not a cure-all. There is no such thing as a cure-all for anything, but it's a great tool.
We've seen absolute miracles with it. And the beauty of it is that just the years that we've
used it, we've had patients that have been complete skeptic, non-believers like me see just
complete miracles with it. There's a placebo effect with any kind of treatment, any kind of treatment
medical or non-medical. And I've just seen over and over where the placebo effect had nothing to
do with this person getting better because they had no beliefs that they wanted yet they still got
better. So, we've seen people with two weeks to live and get better, but again it doesn't work
on everybody. So, they have to have your expectations correct. More about the RIF ad website, this whole
chapter in the book of the RIF is beneficial. There's other books, Barry Lines has written a number of
books on RIF. He's an excellent author. There's several videos out there of the life of royal RIF.
I think I have them tagged in our website that they can be beneficial too.
There's dozens of books on energy medicine written by physicists or people that are
more inclined to that left-brain type knowledge than I am. And they can be valuable to read those.
They're very heady. So, but it's a great tool. Again, many people ask, well, how does it work?
And I can explain a little bit like I do right now. Honestly, I'm a clinician. So, I've got a
physicist. I'm a clinician. And it's so understanding, I just care that it works.
That's my biggest concern. It does it work. And that's great. We're going to use it. So, this is
probably one of my favorite tools of everything. I wouldn't be talking to you if RIF didn't do what
he did. I wish very much that I was able to meet him. He died in 1971. And that wasn't able to
take place with me, but it was he's been a blessing to many, many, many people. And I hope he's in heaven
being knowledge for that. All right. I hope this was beneficial to you. I will see you on the next
section, section seven. And keep up the good fight.